[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
اداره الكوارث التركيه تعلن ارتفاع حصيله
قتل الزلزال لنحو 32
الف وصوله اول دفعه مواد اغاثيه سعوديه
الى حلب ومركز الملك سلمان يكشف عن مجموعه
اخرى قيد التجهيز
التبرعات الشعبيه في السعوديه لضحايا
الزلزال تتجاوز 350 مليون ريال
العربيه تلتقي والد الشاب حمزه الذي توفي
تحت الانقاض في زلزال انطاكيا التركيه
كذلك
صندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه يعلن
استثمارات خمسه مليارات ريال في مجال
البناء والتشييد
حياكم الله اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
في تركيا ان الاحصاءات الرسميه اشارت الى
ان عدد القتلى ارتفع الى 31 الف وتسعمائه
شخصا قضوا جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
فيما تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اجلاء ما يقرب
من تسعه او من 195 الف وتسعمائه
ضحيه من المناطق التي تعرضت للزلزال في
جنوب تركيا اضافت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
ان عمليات البحث مستمره لانقاذ نادينا جدد
كشفت الامم المتحده عن تاثر اكثر من سبعه
ملايين طفل بالزلزال المدمر والهزات
الارتداديه الكبيره التي اعقبته في تركيا
وسوريا الاسبوع الماضي وفق ما اعلنت الامم
المتحده المتحده باسم منظمه اليونس قال ان
مجموعه الاطفال الذين يعيشون في المحافظات
العشر التركيه التي ضربها الزلزالان
4.6 مليون طفل وفي سوريا اثنين مليون ونصف
المليون طفل واشار الى ان المنظمه تخشى
مقتل الاف الاطفال وان التقديرات تؤكد ان
الاعداد مستمره في الازدياد
وصف مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس عبر
حسابه في تويتر الدمار في سوريا عقب
الزلزال بغير المسبوق في حياته مشددا على
ضروره تقديم الدعم لاعاده بناء حياه
الضحايا والمتضررين بعد تضاعف خسائر الحرب
بخسائر الزلزال
نجحت فرق البحث والانقاذ من انقاذ شاب
امضى 198 ساعه تحت الانقاض في اديمان كما
تمكنت الفرق من انقاذ شخصين من تحت
الانقاض في قهرمان مرعش بعد مضيء
1998 ساعه على وقوع الزلزال المدمر وذلك
وفقا لوكاله انباء الاناضول واظهرت لقطات
عمال واظهرت لقطات عمال الانقاذ وهم
يحملون الشخصين اللذين تم انقاذهما على
محبتين في انتظار وصول سيارات الاسعاف
طب هات هات
بدات عمليات ازاله البنايات السكنيه
المتضرره من الزلزال ولم تعد صالحه للسكن
في ديار بكر احدى المقاطعات المنكوبه
نتابع
كم
وينضم الينا من كهرمان مرعش بتركيا مفرد
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض
دعنا نتحدث في البدايه عن صور النازحين من
خلفك كيف يبدو المشهد منذ وصلت الى هناك
ما الذي يقدم لهم حتى هذه اللحظه من فيما
يخص طبعا الايواء المواد الاغاثيه والطبيه
وغيرها مما رصدتهم منذ وصولك
نعم نايف بالفعل منذ ان دخلنا الى قهرمان
مرعش وهي مصدر الرئيسي للزلزال والذي بدات
منه هذا بدا من هذا الزلزال الى ان وصلت
اثاره الى شمالي سوريه هنا الكثير من
الاشخاص ثلث المدينه تقريبا خارج منازلهم
والمتبقي من من هم في منازلهم متبقين وهم
خائفون لا ينامون في الليل في منازلهم
بسبب الهزات الارتداديه التي تحدث بين
الحين والاخر والتصدع المنازل وايضا
الصدمات النفسيه التي تعرضوا لها
يتواجدونهم في اماكن متعدده من الحدائق
والاماكن العامه والملاعب هنا في ملعب
كرمان مرعش حيث يتواجد العدد الاكبر من
النازحين وهو اكبر مكان لتجمع النازحين في
هذه
المنطقه يتواجدون منذ ايام العدد كبير جدا
بالالاف بعضهم مصابين جراء الزلزال والبعض
الاخر لديه بعض الخدوش واست من هذه
الانقاض يتم تقديم لهم كافه المساعدات
الانسانيه
والاغاثيه والغذائيه من مختلف الجهات سواء
كان المحليه
والدوليه في هذا الموقع المكتظ
بالناس و بالنازحين بالاطفال بكافه من
تضرروا بالاضافه الى ان اشخاص من خارج هذه
المدينه قدموا الى هذه المدينه بعد ان
تضررت منازلهم ولم يجدوا ماوى والبحثوا عن
المكان الاكبر الذي يتم فيه تجميع
النازحين وتقديم الخدمات لهم بكافه
انواعها هنالك العديد من فرق الطبيه التي
شاهدتها والعيادات
والمختلف الجهات الاغاثيه الدوليه التي
تعمل لتقديم الخدمات لهم في وسط هذا العدد
الضخم جدا من الاشخاص سالت بعض المسؤولين
هنا عن عدد
اشخاص هنا قال بانه لا يستطيع ان يعطينا
معلومه لان العدد بتزايد كل يوم هنالك
اعداد مستمره بالقدوم الى هذا المنطقه
فبالتالي هنالك حاجه الى مزيد من
المساعدات بالاضافه الى ذلك هنالك
ربما الحال عبد المحسن يعني كنت اريد
السؤال هذه المنطقه تسجل فيها هزات
ارتداديه منذ يعني تقريبا ثمانيه ايام
يعني بعد زلزال مباشره الرئيسي هل برصدت
اي هزات ارتداديه منذ وصولك الى قهرمان
مرعش وكيف يعني يتعامل السكان الان معها
بعد ان وحتى اللاجئني الى داخل هذه
المدينه
نعم يوم الامس نايف حدثت اليوم صباحا منذ
اتينا لم يكن هنالك هزات ارتداديه شعرنا
بها ولكن يوم الامس كان هنالك هزه
ارتداديه بقياس اربعه فاصله خمسه على
مقياس رختر في كهرمان مرعش شعره بها
السكان بالاضافه لذلك ارتداداتها الى حيث
كنا نتواجد يوم الامس في غازي عنتاب حيث
شعارنا بهذه الهزه في منطقه غازي عنتاب
وهي انطلقت من هذه
المنطقه بالاضافه الى ان الهزات
الارتداديه اصبحت معتاده لدى السكان هنا
بعد ان اصبح اصبحت عبد المحسن بدرجه اقل
من الايام التي مضت مركز الملك سلمان ايضا
هو الاخر عبد المحسن يقدم
الخدمات الاغاثه
والخدمات ايضا كذلك الانسانيه للمناطق
الشماليه في سوريا كما تابعنا اليوم لكن
فيما يخص كهرمان المركز الزلزال هل هناك
مساعدات اغاثيه وصلت بالفعل من مركز الملك
سلمان الى هذه المنطقه المنكوبه
نعم بالفعل نايف بدات اعمل مركز الملك
سلمان والفرق الاغاثيه السعوديه بشكل عام
في عدد من المناطق وتنتقل من منطقه الى
اخرى بالتنسيق مع افاد وهي الجهه المسؤوله
عن هذه
المساعدات فبالتالي تم توجيهه الى غازي
عنتاب واضنه ومن ثم اتت الى هنا الى الى
قهرمان مرعش حيث بعد قليل سيصل فريق سعودي
اغاثي ليتم توزيع مساعدات ايوائيه وغذائيه
وايضا كسوه شتائيه لهؤلاء النازحين في هذه
المنطقه في عمليه مستمره لعمليات الاغاثه
لمركز الملك سلمان وكافه الجهات الاغاثيه
السعوديه بالاضافه الى ان فريق الانقاذ
انتقل من منطقه من منطقه غازيه عنتاب في
الابراهيملي بعد ان توقفت بشكل شبه
تام بشكل يعني بقيت
نعم غازي عنتاب لا تتوفر المدافع في لدى
الاشخاص فبالتالي هنا على الرغم من
الاقتضاء الظهير من تواجد الفرق هنا لكن
الخدمات تقدم بشكل جيد على الاقل في هذه
اللحظات للفرق او للنازحين المتواجدين في
هذه المنطقه في قهرمان شاه منفدل العربيه
من كهرمان مرعش بتركيا عبد المحسن الحربي
يشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
بعد ايام من دخول المساعدات السعوديه
لضحايا الزلزال في شمال سوريا عبر المنافذ
الحدوديه مع تركيا وصلت فجر اليوم عبر
الجو شحنه مساعدات سعوديه مباشره الى حلب
السوريه المشرف والعام على مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه الدكتور
عبد الله الربيع قال للعربيه بان الطائره
الاغاثيه الاولى وصلت الى مطار حلب الدولي
وعلى متنها لوازم ايوائيه ومواد غذائيه
وطبيبيه لمساعده الفئات الاكثر تضررا
الطائره التي وصلت
صباح هذا اليوم تحمل على متنها لوازم
كيوائيه تشمل خيام وبطانيات واحتياجات
الاسر الضروريه وكذلك مواد وسلال غذائيه
وادويه واجهزه طبيه ومستلزمات طبيه هذه هي
الطائره الاولى
ولدينا عدد من الطائرات سوف
يغادر خلال الساعات القادمه
بجدوله منظمه من الرياض الى حلب لضمان
وصول المساعدات الى الاسر والمجتمع الاكثر
تضررا في سوريا
الربيعه كشفها للعربيه بان طائره السعوديه
الاغافيه الاولى لسوريا سيتبعها سلسله من
الطائرات الاغاثيه التي يجري تجهيزها
عاجلا لمساعده المتضررين بالتعاون مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري طبعا احنا بالنسبه
راح نسقنا مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري الذي سبق وان
تعاملنا معه
واكد لنا انه سوف يستمر كما مع عمل معنا
بالسابق بايصالها الى مستحقيها والى
المنظمات التي نعمل معها كان هنالك تواصل
من خلال هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري بضمان وصول هذه
المساعدات ونزول الطائرات الى الاراضي
السوريه وكما شاهدتم نزلت الطائره الاولى
ونحن الان وانا اتحدث معكم نجهز الطائره
الثانيه وسوف يدفعها اكثر من طائره لضمان
وصول هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل
الدكتور عبد الله ربيعه كداله العربيه
كذلك بان المركز يعمل مع مؤسسات المجتمع
المدني السوري وخلال الايام الماضيه تم
ادخال الشاحنات المساعدات السعوديه من
خلال الحدود السوريه التركيه
طبعا الاليه كما اعلناها المركز يعمل مع
مؤسسات ومنظمات المجتمع المدني الموثوقه
في الداخل السوري
اكثر من يومين ادخلنا عدد كبير من
الشاحنات من الحدود التركيه السوريه الى
شمال سوريا واليوم بدا الجسر الجوي والى
الى الى حلب
وننسق في الداخل مع
مؤسساتهم ومنظمات مجتمع مدني سبق التعامل
معها منذ سنوات وهي موثوقه على المستوى
الدولي وعلى المستوى المحلي
كما كاد المشرف على مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه بان الفرق المعنيه في مركز الملك
سلمان تدرسه امكانيه اعاده اعمار المناطق
المنكوبه جراء الزلزال المدمر
المساعدات السعوديه بالعكس كامله وشامله
نحن الان نستجيب
الاحتياجات الضروريه والعاجله جدا لانقاذ
الحياه كما شاهدتم طرق انقاذ اطباء كوادر
صحيه فرق متطوعين مواد اغاثيه مواد طبيه
اجهزه كذلك بطانيات خيام وكذلك اجهزه
تدفئه يتبعها كذلك الوجود على الارض يوجد
فرق تقييم للاحتياج ما بعد الاحتياجات
الطارئه من ضمنها كذلك انشاء اولا ماوى
مؤقت يتبعه كذلك ان شاء الله من خلال
الدراسات التي تقوم بها الفرق المعنيه في
مركز الملك سلمان
بدراسه امكانيه كذلك
اعاده الاعمار
هذا وتجاوز حجم المساعدات الشعبيه في
السعوديه عبر منصه ساهم التي تتبع لمركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
تجاوزت 351 مليون ريال لدعم ضحايا الزلزال
المدمر في تركيا وسوريا التي تبرع بها
اكثر من مليون و500 الف شخص بين مواطن
ومقيم في السعوديه
من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي بين سوريا
وتركيا ينضم الي نصيحه في محمد الاشقر
محمد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره محمد
يعني هذا المعبر حتى هذه اللحظه كيف يمكن
تقييم شاحنات الاغاثه والمساعدات ايضا
كذلك التي عبرت منه الى الداخل السوري وهل
لازال هذا المعبر يعمل حتى الان على
استقبالها ان توقف
نعم يعني في الحقيقه تستمر حركه القوافل
الانسانيه والوفود بالدخول الى سوريا عبر
بوابه باب الهواء الحدوديه مع تركيا طبعا
اليوم دخلت قافله مساعدات امميه مؤلفه من
26 شاحنه تحمل بداخلها الخيام ومستلزماتها
وبعض المواد الاغاثيه طبعا تم تسليمها
فورا
للمنظمات المحليه شريكه التي تعتبر شريكه
للامم المتحده لكي تتوجه بشكل مباشر ويتم
توزيعها بشكل فوري على المتضررين نتيجه
هذا الزلزال طبعا بالاضافه لدخول عده
قوافل انسانيه تابعه لجمعيات خيريه متنوعه
وجمعيات انسانيه سواء كان تركيا او عربيه
بالاضافه لدخول وفد طبي مؤلف
14 طبيب سوري مقيمون في الخارج هؤلاء
الاطباء يعملون
باختصاصات نوعيه دخلوا اليوم وسيبداون
عملهم في المشافي في شمال غرب سوريا طبعا
يعني الى حد هذه اللحظه هذه هي حركه
المعبر باب الهوى هذا المعبر الذي يسمح
بدخول القوافل الامميه فقط منه مع مع وجود
اربعه معابر اخر اخرى في ريف حلب
الشمالي مثل معبر باب السلامه معبر حمام
معبر الراعي ومعبر جرابلس تلك المعابر
تدخل منها المساعدات يعني العربيه فقط مثل
مساعدات المبنى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
من المقدمه من مركز الملك سلمان عندما
دخلت قافله من معبر حمام وتوجهت الى
المناطق المتضرره في مدينه جنديرس ومحيطها
ايضا هناك يعني مساعدات دخلت من هذه
المعابر باتجاه شمال غرب سوريا من الحملات
الشعبيه وحملات التبرع التي اقيمت طيب
محمد يعني او حتى الشعوب العربيه اريد ان
اسال كذلك عن اليه اليه توزيع هذه
المساعده ربما هي المهمه في هذا الوقت
هناك مناطق في حاجه وهناك مناطق في حاجه
اهم او اشد احتياجا واهميه من غيرها
ما هي الاليه اليه توزيع هذه المساعده واي
المناطق هي التي تحتاجها بشده فعلا في هذه
الايام
نعم نعم طبعا الجميع هنا يعلم يعمل على
نظام الاولويه اي يعطون الاولويه للاشد
تضررا طبعا تتوجه مختلف المنظمات المحليه
او شريكه المنظمات الدوليه والعربيه
باتجاه المناطق الاشد تضررا يعني شاهدنا
عده منظمات وهيئات محليه وعالميه اتجهت
نحو مدينه جنديرس في ريف حلب وفي ريف ادلب
هناك العديد من المنظمات توجهت الى
المناطق الاشد التضررا مثل مدن حارم
وسلقين وارمناز ومليس ومنطقه بسنيا هذه
المنطقه التي تدمرت بشكل شبه كامل يعني
نحن نتحدث في هذه المنطقه الصغيره على
اكثر من 123 منزل سويوا في الارض تماما
طبعا الى حد هذه اللحظه نتيجه يعني
الاستيعاب الكارثه والاسراب باستيعاب
نتيجه عدد المتضررين الذين
قدروا بالالاف الى الجميع يعمل بنظام
الاولويه ان يبدا التوزيع للاشد تضررا وهم
الذين بلا ماوى الافضليه الان يعني الطلب
الاول من قبل الناجين من هذا الزلزال
والمتضررين هو ايجاد ماوى لهم هناك العديد
من العائلات الى حد هذه اللحظه بلا ماوى
هناك العديد منهم لا يزالون في مراكز
الايواء المؤقته هذه المراكز التي تفصل
فيها العائله اي ان الرجال في خيام
والنساء في خيام الاستيعاب اكبر عدد ممكن
من المتضررين ضمن هذه المراكز اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي بين
سوريا وتركيا انضم الى نصيحه في محمد
الاشقر
تعرضت مدينه حلب ثاني اكبر المدن السوريه
لاضرار جسيمه في الارواح والبنيه التحتيه
حيث لحقت الاضرار بابرز المعالم التاريخيه
للمدينه بعضها يعود لالاف السنين
الضرر لحق باهم المعالم التاريخيه للمدينه
ابرزها قلعه حلب
قوه الزلزال هدمت اجزاء من اسوار القلعه
وتسببت بتشققات في جدرانها
كذلك تضررت مناره الجامع الايوبي ومساجد
وكنائس يعود بعضها الى العهد العثماني
امتدت اثار الزلزال الى المدينه القديمه
وبواباتها المتعدده باب انطاكيا من جهه
الغرب كان اكثر ابواب المدينه الاثريه
تضررا الدمار الحق ايضا بالاسواق
التاريخيه كسوق الجوخ وسوق خان الوزير
ومحلهما التجاريه
انتقدت مجموعه الانقاذ التي تديرها
المعارضه السوريه قرار الامم المتحده منحى
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد اتخاذ قرار
بالسماح بتسليم المساعدات الانسانيه الى
شمال غرب سوريا من خلال المعابر الحدوديه
مع تركيا مشيره الى ان الامر يعطي مكاسب
سياسيه مجانيه للاسد
من بلده حارب السوريه ينضم الينا الصحفي
مسلم السيد عيسى السيد مسلم مرحبا بك معي
في هذه النشره في نشره الرابعه كيف هي
الاوضاع الركاب من خلفك ويبدو ايضا ان فرق
الانقاذ والبحث يعني توقفت عن عملياتها
ربما لاننا قد يعني مرت ايام طويله على
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب هذه المدينه
في الحقيقه يعني لم تتوقف فرق الدفاع
المدني والانقاذ بعد بدء المرحله الثانيه
كما قالت من رفع الانقاض والبحث عن جثه
القتلى لكن بالمقابل هناك مئات الابلاغات
التي سجلت من قبل الاهالي عن فقدهم لمئات
الاشخاص تحت اسقف هذه المنازل وهذه
المباني المدمره بشكل كامل كما تشاهدون
ساحاول عبر عدسه الكاميرا نقل الصوره من
خلفي لا تزال فرق الدفاع المدني كما
تشاهدون تعمل على رفع هذه الانقاذ البحث
عن الناجين ربما وايضا محاوله يعني
تثبت من عدم وجود جثث للقتله وبالمقابل
ايضا الدفاع المدني
ومديريه الصحه قالت انها لا وجود لاي
مؤشرات لوجود احياء تحت هذه المباني لكنها
تعمل على خطه طويله الامد قد تستغرق 15
يوم الى 20 يوم لانتشال كامل الجثث ممن
فقدوا في هذه الاماكن نحن هنا في بلده
حارم وهي بلده صغيره على الحدود السوريه
التركيه حجم الدمار فيها كان هائلا لكن
فرق الانقاذ والدفاع المدني يعني تقوم
بواجبها بحسب الامكانيات يعني ممكن
تشاهدوا في الصوره الشاحنه الصغيره التي
توضع فيها هذه التلال الركام لابعادها من
المنطقه حتى تستطيع فرق الدفاع المدني
محاوله استمرار في البحث عن جثث المفقودين
لكن بالمقابل كما ذكرت هناك الاهالي لا
زالوا ينتظرون هنا في هذا المكان ايد خبر
سواء عن جثث مفقوديهم او حتى ايجادهم في
المستشفيات وغيرها الحاله هنا تزداد
كارثيه وفوضى نتيجه عدم وجود في الايام
الاولى كانت الاتصالات والانترنت وغيرها
وبالتالي الاهالي ابلغت عن مفقودين قد
يكونوا في المستشفيات قد يكونوا تحت
الانقاذ وهذا ما اثر بشكل كبير على عدم
وجود احصائيه دقيقه
للمفقودين تحت انقاذ منازلهم وبالتالي هذه
الاحصائيه بحسب هنا الدفاع المدني قد
تتضاعف الى ضعفين او ثلاثه اضعاف ربما لان
الكارثه لم تبدا بعد بحسب ما هي الارقام
الحاليه الموجوده الان مسلم
مسلم طيب
يبدو ان فقدنا الصحفي مسلم هل تسمعني
نعم نعم قبل قليل عن الارقام التقديره
للضحايا للمصابين حتى هذه اللحظه لديك
والتي توقعوا ان تزداد خلال الايام
المقبله كم هي الاعداد التقديريه الحاليه
منذ الزلزاله وحتى هذه اللحظه
نعم يعني ما وثقه حتى اللحظه فقط واتحدث
عن شمال غرب سوريا
2270 قتيل بالاضافه
الى الخمسه
الاف المستشفيات تغوص بالمصابين تحدث نحن
هنا عن مستشفيات ميدانيه غير مؤهله
للتعامل مع هذه الحالات كانت في الايام
الاولى
يعني الساحات المستشفيات مليئه بالجثث
وايضا داخلها في غرف العمليات المصابين
هذه الارقام كما ذكرت هي مؤهله للزياده
لضعفين او ثلاثه اضعاف لانها كما تشاهدون
يعني من خلفي لا تزال عمليات البحث عن جثث
المفقودين قبل قليل كنا في مداخله ايضا
جاء احد الاهالي ابلغ عن وجود خمس عوائل
في البناء من خلفه في الصوره كانت هذه
العوائل ليس لديها اي شخص قد ابلغ عنها
لانها نازحه من الباديه السوريه وانتقلت
الى هذه المنطقه وبالتالي اكتشاف الحالات
ربما
سيكون كبيرا خلال ايام القليله القادمه
وما هذا ما سيؤثر على ازدياد اعداد
ممن قدروا تحت ركام منازلهم وايضا ممن
نجوا ستكون الحاله كارثيه لانهم لا يزالون
في الطرقات والشوارع اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
بلده حارم السوريه انضم الينا صحفي مسلم
السيد هيثم
لم تسعف الظروف ولا الاوراق الثبوتيه
الشابه حمزه الصفواني البالغ 17 عاما
بالعوده الى السعوديه واستكمال اوراقه
الرسميه والعيش برفقه عائله ابي حيث توفي
تحت انقاذ احدى البنايات بمدينه انطاكيا
التركيه العربيه التقت والده حمزه الذي
روى قصه اقامه وحياه ابنه هناك
[موسيقى]
قطعه مني كيف حتى الحين ابكي علي ولدي
والله كل شويه ابكي بس الحمد لله
هذه الكلمات المؤثره تحدث مصطفى الصفواني
والد الشاب حمزه الذي توفي في مدينه
انطاكيا التركيه تحدث لكاميرا العربيه حول
تفاصيل وفاته جراء الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب المدينه انا قبل اربع ايام
بس مو انه ولدي يموت
اربع ايام عزيت خلاص
قبل الزلزال والله والله والله
في نفس الليله وانا قاعد على سجادتي قبل
الفجر قلت ان شاء الله اجيب ولدي قبل لا
يصير شي مشاكل هناك في تركيا بيجي بيجي ان
شاء الله بس بعد القطع والقدم الحمد لله
والشكر
هذا الاب كان ينتظر عوده ابنه الى حضنه
بعد غيابه لسنوات طويله حيث عاش حمزه مع
والدته في سوريا قبل ان ينتقل الى تركيا
قبل عامين تمهيدا لعودته الى عائله ابيه
في صفوه شرقه السعوديه
يشبهها اطباع اخواننا بالضغط
حتى حركاته
ابدا يعني امس جاي احنا في القبر ومسوي
عزا في الليل
نفس ايش فكروا اخوه جواهر اللي توفى هو
جواد يلا استاذ في مدرسه اليرموك مدرسه
الفكريها فكرناك انت لاني يشبهوا الحمد
لله الله يعطيه والله ياخذ تقريبا قبل شهر
كان تواصل معاي
والحمد لله رب العالمين على كل حال ما
نقدر نقول الا غير الحمد لله كنا نترقب
جيته في اقرب وقت ممكن
بس ان شاء الله
وشاءت الاقدار والحمد لله على كل حال ما
نقدر نقول غير الحمد لله مصطفى تواصل مع
ابنه المتوفي قبل ايام قليله من رحيله
مبينا انه كان يعيش برفقه جدته من امه في
انطاكيا التي نجت باعجوبه من الزلزال بعد
اخراجها من تحت الانقاض راحوا يوم الجمعه
في الصباح راحوا والله فتشل شافوا هذه
شافوا
ظاهره جدته ظاهر راسها
وقعدوا يحفروا فراوله طلعوها في ودوها
المستشفى الحمد لله ما فيها اشي
ولا حمزه
قال توفى
الحمد لله
حمزه ليس الابن الوحيد الذي فقد حياته في
عائله مصطفى هناك ابن اخر له توفي غرقا
قبل عده سنوات بمدينه صفوان ولا يزال
مصطفى الصفواني صابرا على هذا الفقد رغم
حزنه العميق الواضح على ملامحه المنهكى
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه صفوا العربيه
الرابع مستمر وفيها بعد قليل
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه يقول بان نيتو
سيواصل تقديم انظمه الدفاع الجوي
والدبابات لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديدة وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه بان دول النيتو ستواصل تزويد
اوكرانيا بانظمه الدفاع الجوي والدبابات
كما اكد على بحث مبادرات تصنيع تضمن
استمراريه دعم اوكرانيا على المدى البعيد
واضاف اوستن ان الدعم الذي يقدم لاوكرانيا
بلغ مستويات تاريخيه
سنبحث في مبادرات صناعيه تضمن استمراريه
دعمنا لاوكرانيا على المدى البعيد ايضا
سنبحث في المسؤوليات المتعلقه بالدعم
الامني الذي نقدمه لاوكرانيا والذي بلغ
مستويات تاريخيه اوكرانيا ملتزمه بان
الدعم العسكري الذي تتلقاه سيصل الى
الجنود الاوكرانيين على الجبهات هذا
الاجتماع ياتي في وقت حرج الكرملين مازال
يراهن ان بمقدوره ان يفرقنا لكن بعد عام
من الحرب ما زلنا متحدين كما كنا سابقا
الامين العام لحلف الناتو التام الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بعدم الاهتمام
بجهود وقف الحرب واحلال السلام مشيرا الى
ان ما يجري على الارض يؤكد رغبه بوتين شن
هجمه جديده
الاسبوع المقبل الذكرى الاولى للحرب في
اوكرانيا والغزو الروسي لا نرى اي مؤشرات
على ان الرئيس بوتين يستعد للسلام بل
العكس يستعد لمواصله الحرب وشن هجمات
جديده من المهم ان يقدم الحلفاء وشركاء
الناتو المزيد من الدعم الاوكرانيا سنعالج
الاحتياجات العاجله لزياده الدعم لكييف
بينها توفير المزيد من الاسلحه والذخيره
وتقويه صناعه الدفاع وتجديد المخزون
العسكري يجب ان تحصل اوكرانيا على اسلحه
تضمن انتصارها
اعلن ناطق باسم الكرملين
ان حلف شمال الاطرسي يؤكد عداءه تجاه
روسيا في كل يوم ويبذل قصار جهده لجعل
مشاركته في الصراع الاوكراني واضحه قدر
الامكان وقال بيسكوف ان الامر يتطلب اتخاذ
تدابير احتياطيه لمواجهه اعداء النيتو
من بروكس المراسل العربيه نور الدين
الفريد ينضم الينا نور الدين مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
تصريحات لود اوستن كانت تتحدث
بان مجموعه من الدول الاوروبيه ستزود
اوكرانيا بالدبابات كذلك ايضا انظمه
الدفاع الجويه حتى اللحظه كيف
تتعامل اوروبا مع هذه الطلبات الى اين
وصلوا فيما يخص موضوع الانظمه انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الدبابات نعلم ربما باننا
الموضوع حسم خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
اهلا نايف نعم نقاشات مكثفه تجري في هاته
اللحظات في مقر حلف شمال الاطلسي ولكن
داخل المنصه او على مستوى المنصه التي
تديرها الولايات المتحده وهي منصه لجنه
دعم او لجنه الاتصال لدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
وفي هذا الاجتماع يتوقع بعد تقريبا ساعه
ان يعلن عن التزامي اتي الدول تقريبا
خمسين دوله من الناتو من الدول الغربيه
وايضا من اطراف اخرى بمواصله دعم اوكرانيا
على الصيد عسكري في هذه المرحله بالذات
النقاشات تتركز حول تزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات وهذا حصل على مستوى القرار
السياسي ولكن
الجهود تتعلق الان باسرعي في تدريب
الاوكرانيين على استخدام هذه الدبابات لان
مثل ما اكد الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلس
المساله ليست بهاته البساطه ان دبابه تنقل
الى الداخل الاوكراني وبالتالي تتوفر لا
الدبابه سلاح ثقيل يحتاج الى
الذخيره يحتاج الى قطع الخيار يحتاج الى
الصيانه يحتاج ايضا الى التنسيق معه انظمه
الدفاع الاخرى وخاصه انظمه الدفاع الجوي
والمدفعيه التي توجد في مناطق اخرى ربما
اماميه ولكن على مستوى
اللجستينعم تحدث عن ان ثماني دول اوروبيه
هي المانيا بولندا كندا البرتغال اسبانيا
هولندا هاته الدول ستزود اوكرانيا باكثر
من 90 دبابه من طراز عفوا هذه الدول ستزود
اوكرانيا بدبابه الالمانيه
ايضا الولايات المتحده وجمهوريه التشيك
وهولندا ستزود اوكرانيا باكثر من 90 دبابه
من طراز تي 72 وكذلك بولندا تزود اوكرانيا
بهايه الدبابات اضافه الى نبات
البريطانيه هذا اضافه
الى ان الولايات المتحده تعمل مع المانيا
وهولندا على تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه صواريخ
باتريوت وايطاليا وفرنسا تعملان ايضا على
تزويدها بنظام الدفاع الجوي اس ام تي
لكن كلها نعم هناك نوع قد يبدو ان هناك
نوع من البطء او البعد الزمنيه ايام تفرق
بين اتخاذ القرار السياسي
والوصول هل هل هل هناك من طبعا ربما
يعني
خلاف او اختلاف مع الولايات المتحده من
قبل هذه الدول الاوروبيه فيما تطلبه من
دبابات من انظمه الدفاع ايضا كذلك جويه هل
هناك توافق بين الدول ام لا زالت يعني
النقاشات تاخذ ابعاد مختلفه وربما لا يتم
التوافق مع كل هذه الدول لانه محدده دولا
بعينها ولم يتحدث عن كافه دول حلف النيتو
هذا لا يعني بان هناك خلافات هناك دول لها
اوضاع محدده مثلا فرنسا لها عدد محدود من
الدبابات الثقيله للكليريك بلجيكا
دباباتها من اليوبو كانت باعتها في نوع
باعتها قبل قبل فتره الولايات المتحده نعم
لا تريد تزويد اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله
بدبابات ابرمس لانها يبدو من الناحيه
الصناعيه والتكتيكيه لا ربما في هذه
المرحله لا يمكن الدبابات ان تكون ذات
جدوى كبيره او انها دقيقه جدا وهناك
تكنولوجيا دقيقه جدا في نهايه الدبابات
الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان تتواجد في
الميدان الاوكراني لان هذه الاسلحه هي
اسلحه دقيقه ثقيلا عام ولكن تكنولوجي
متقدمه جدا ونعم دول مثل فرنسا او
الولايات المتحده لا تريد لي ان تضع تقع
دبابه الفرنسيه او ابرامسل الامريكيه بين
ايدي القوات الروسيه لانها ستكون غنيمه
تكنولوجيه في وقت تعاني في روسيا او تواجه
في روسي عقوبات شديده فيما يتعلق
بالتكنولوجيا العسكريه الدقيقه هناك مساله
اخرى تطرح سريع او في الكواليس لكنها لم
تعلن هي مساله
مدى مدى التجاوب مع طلب
المقاتلات البريطانيون سيدربون الطيارين
طيارين اوكرانيين ولكن هذه المساله ليست
مطروحه رسميا في نقاشات اليوم
مراسل العربيه من بروكسل شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل دائما
ومن مطار الملك خالد بالرياض نعود طبعا
الى الملف
الزلازل في تركيا والسوريه من مطار الملك
خالد بالرياض ينضم الينا مدير دعم
العمليات في مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه فالحب بن هيمان
السبيعي سيد فالح مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض للتو وعدت من حلب بعد
ان وصل الطائره اغاثه سعوديه الى مطار حلب
الدولي كيف تجري الامور هناك كيف تقيمها
كذلك ما هي نوعيه المساعدات التي كانت
علامات هذه الطائره السعوديه التي اتجهت
الى حلب صباح اليوم
اهلا وسهلا فيكم وفي المشاهدين الكرام في
الحقيقه انه المصاب كبير في
المتضررين في سوريا من جراء الزلزال طبعا
التنسيقات جرت لايصال عدد من الطائرات الى
مطار حلب بعد وصول الاذونات او ما قبل
وصول الاذونات كان هناك توجيه من
القياده بايصال المساعدات التي وصلتها او
جزء من المشاهدات التي وصلت الطائرات الى
تركيا الى عبر الحدود السوريه التركيه
الداخل السوري وفورا الحصول على الاذونات
تم تسيير هذا الخط الجوي وهذه الطائره
الاولى وتحمل اكثر من 35 طن من المساعدات
الغذائيه والايوائيه والمواد الطبيه وحليب
الاطفال كم من المتوقع ان تفيدون طائره
الى حلب خلال الايام القادمه من خلال هذا
الجسر الجوي المباشر بين الرياض ومطار حلب
الدولي
طبعا مقرر حتى الان ثلاث طائرات وصلت
الطائره الاولى اليوم وبفضل الله تم
التنسيق واستلامها من قبل الهلال الاحمر
السوري وسوف تقلع الطائره الثانيه غدا
صباحا وهناك طائره ثالثه مجدوله بعد غد
يوم الخميس وسوف يقيم مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه امكانيه الحاجه الى طائرات اخرى
طيب الحديث ايضا كذلك عن نوعيه المساعدات
التي ستكون في الطائره الثانيه في الطائره
ايضا كذلك الثالثه عن الاحتياجات ايضا
التي يعني
تحتاج اليها الان حلب في مثل هذه الاوقات
يعني نحن نتحدث عن لاجئين نتحدث عن
متضررين نتحدث عن مصابين ايضا كذلك نتحدث
ايضا حتى عن ربما معدات ثقيله تساعد فرق
البحث والانقاذ او ربما فرق ازاله الركام
هناك
طبعا بالدرجه الاولى المركز يركز على
الاحتياجات الاغاثيه والانسانيه هو يحاول
المحافظه على حياه الانسان في مثل هذه
الكوارث هناك احتياج شديد جدا للمواد
الغذائيه والمواد الايوائيه نتيجه
تدمر المنازل وسقوطها فيكون هناك احتياج
عالي للمواد الغذائيه والايوائيه وكذلك
المواد الطبيه فهذه الشحنات تضمنت على هذا
على هذه الاشياء ووردتنا كذلك بالتنسيق ما
بين الهلال الاحمر السعودي والهلال الاحمر
السوري هذه الطلبات ومن ضمنها حليب
الاطفال الذي تم تامينه
لاسرى الضحايا فهل ستستمر
المساعدات الاغاثيه التي تدخل عبر
الشاحنات من المنافذ التركيه الى الداخل
السوري هل ستستمر هي ايضا كذلك بالعمل امس
تكتفون بهذه الطائرات من الرياض الى مطار
حلب الدولي بشكل مباشر
طبعا هذه المساعدات هي مساعدات عاجله
سواء عن طريق الشاحنات عبر الحدود التركيه
السوريه او عبر الطائرات التوجيه صدر من
القياده الكريمه في المملكه بان يكون
التدخل لجميع المناطق المتضرره في سوريا
للوقوف بجانب الشعب السوري الشقيق وفي حال
هدوء الازمه سوف يتم العمل على تنفيذ
مشاريع بشكل اكبر عن طريق شركائنا
الانسانيين في الداخل السوري فهل تقصد
مشاريع عاده الاعمار في في مناطق سوريه في
مناطق شمال سوريا
انا اتحدث عن مشاريع المشاريع اللقافيه
والانسانيه وفيما يخص مشاريع اعاده اعمار
هذه تخضع للتقييم من قبل عده جهات في
المملكه ولكن المركز يركز حاليا على
المواد الاغاثيه والانسانيه وهي الحياه
وهي الفتره المهمه في حياه الكارثه اتكلم
عن مشاريع ما بعد
الطائرات ان يتم التعاقد مع الشركاء
الانسانيين على الارض وتنفيذ مشاريع بشكل
وبوتيره متناسبه حتى تستطيع ان تعود تلك
المناطق الى التعافي اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
هذه الدقائق من الرياض مدير دعم العمليات
بمركز الملك سلمان للغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه فالحه بالدهيمان السبيعي
الرابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
صندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه يعني انه
استثمارها 5 مليارات ريال في مجال البناء
والتشييد
[موسيقى]
هذه اللحظه اللي يبدا فيها قلم يخف واشعر
فيها اني راح انام طول الليل مع باند
[موسيقى]
وحيويه التحرر من الالم يبدا
يد الام يا مشاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسا تعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بيدين الامهات
لدينا القاعده الاساسيه في قيام الدوله
وهذا الجانب الذي كان يفقد في هذه المنطقه
لماذا نشات الدوله السعوديه الاولى وما هي
الاصوات التي كانت تطلبها جانب الامني هو
اعم عامل لقيام الدوله من سنه 850 كما
ذكرت الى عام 1839 انظر الى الفتره
التاريخيه القديمه ربما من اكبر يعني اطول
الاسرات الحاكمه في العالم لماذا شخصيه
محمد بن سعود مهمه قبل ان يلتقي بمحمد بن
عبد الوهاب الندوه مع مشاري الذايدي محمد
بن سعود اول من وحد اجزاء الدرعيه اتصال
وتواصل ايضا اجتماعي وايضا لم هذه القرى
المتفرقه في الدرعيه الجزء الاول السبت
3:30 على شاشه العربيه
المناعه القويه تبدا بعدد صحيه
مع فيتامين سي وزنك وفيتامين دال يساعد
على تعزيز مناعتك يوم بعد يوم خلي سنترم
جزء من روتينك اليومي
[موسيقى]
اعلن صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعوديه
عن استثماري خمسه مليارات ريال في اربع
شركات وطنيه تعمل في مجال خدمات البناء
والتشغيل حيث ستسهم الاستثمارات في رفع
حجم المحتوى المحلي وزياده الناتج المحلي
الاجماليه للسعوديه بالاضافه لتعزيز سلاسل
الامداد والتوريد عبر الرفع من تنافسيه
قطاع خدمات البناء والتشييد وزياده سعته
الانتاجيه وتطوير قدراته كما سيعمل
الصندوق على تمكين الشركات من تطوير
علاقات اقليميه ودوليه في القطاع بهدف
زياده الاعتماد على التقنيات الجديده في
البناء ونقل المعرفه للسوق المحلي
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
اداره الكوارث التركيه تعلن ارتفاع حصيله
قتل الزلزال نحو 32 الف
وصول اول دفعه لمواد الاغاثه السعوديه الى
حلب ومركز الملك سلمان يكشف عن مجموعه
اخرى قيد التجهيز
اعتبرات الشعبيه في السعوديه لضحايا
الزلزال تتجاوز 350 مليون ريال
العربيه تلتقي والد الشاب حمزه الذي توفي
تحت الانقاض في زلزال انطاكيا التركيه
صندوق الاستثمارات السعودي يعلن استثمارها
خمسه مليارات ريال في مجال البناء
والتشييد
شكرا ولطف المتابعه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]